hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday hey hey hey
june 13 2022
[Music]
what's going on how are ya
how's it going everybody
how was your weekend ben has it been
good did you have a good one i hope you
did
look at this it's already june 13th the
summer is just flying by
you know
have you taken the time to fill up your
above ground pool yet
get in there after a couple of sliders
you know what's great about an above
ground pool
you know
as an adult if you drown in an above
ground pool it's just like
you know i gotta google that at some
point there's there's no [__] way
there's no diving board your feet are on
the ground
i mean it's basically
a giant it's like the ice copy coffee
version of like a [__]
hot tub
it's for everybody everybody just stands
there they have the elbows on the edges
the above ground pool
you know what i mean
it's a great way to clean your driveway
at the end of the [__] season
just open that door let it all run out
neighbors across the street with both
arms out the classic
[__] serious
and then you hit him with the eyebrows
up
like is there a problem you know those
silent [__] things you have with your
neighbor
he's got his arms out you got your
eyebrows up
whoever talks first loses
dude i am absolutely [__] obsessed
with power washing
got this uh this is i don't know what
the [__] it is these these berries
cherries berries not sherry's berries
these are just regular berries i
wouldn't eat them because i know some
berries are uh
they're poisonous
according to some of the fairy tales
that i used to read can you say fairy
tales anymore is that considered
homophobic
there's not one gay character in this
sorry the uh what would you call it the
um
lightning loafer's tails whatever the
[__] you're supposed to say um
anyway uh yeah you don't eat the berries
the witch makes you eat em
right
and i love how the stepsisters were ugly
i didn't buy that part you know that
that cinderella was gorgeous and the
stepsisters were ugly they should they
should have made the stepsisters
you know beautiful anyway
i mean they already established that
there are a couple of [__] so like
why do you got to do the double whammy
where they're they're [__] and they're
ugly
i gotta be honest with you there's not
too many ugly [__] out there you have
to have a certain level of beauty
to be a [__] that's not true look at me
i'm a guns gun
um anyway it sounded good sometimes
things in your head sound good and you
say him out loud you like the math
doesn't add up on that
jesus christ that just brought me to
some bad [__] memories
solving problems during a test
in math class
then you do this you carry the one first
outside inside last and this doesn't
[__] add up
the worst one the worst one was when you
had the answer
and you had to come up with the [__]
question because
when you just had to come up with an
answer when they just gave you a
question you had that hope that hey you
know maybe i got it
i mean it felt good you know my hand
wasn't shaking when i wrote those
numbers maybe uh who knows
and a broken clocks right today
right you had that you had that
you had that going for you but when the
answer was already there
and the question didn't add up
you know that's when your bottom lip
started going
are you crying
no
there's no crying in algebra 2
stay after class i want to talk to you
all right
[__] class bell would ring
and you start walking out like you know
hoping he forgot the what he just said
to you 45 seconds ago you know mr burr
i believe we had a little bit
[Music]
your friends laughed they went off to
lunch
to go eat a square [__] rectangle slice
of pizza
also known as a grandmother slice
a sicilian slice
a bathroom tile of [__]
carbohydrates they go you know it's
usually served with a cider green beans
or something [__] stupid whatever
they had leftover as a vegetable to make
it seem like they were trying
you know that's all you had to do back
when i was coming up in school
something gross and then like a [__]
whatever vegetable is left over it's
just like hey you know what do you what
do you want for [__]
cents then remember it was a dollar five
[__] [__] just just call it a
dollar
the [__] guys sitting there walking
around with nickels
um
now here's your five nickels for the
week and here's your five dollars keep
these together these are a set
okay ma
um
actually that's not true i never even
had to bug my [__] parents
for lunch money you know why i had a
[__] job
i was out there every morning delivering
the papers the papers
by the way rest in peace ray liotta
one of the greatest actors of all time
uh
unreal you know i didn't even bring that
up on the last one i think i was just so
in shock
that he passed i actually got to do a
couple of scenes with him in a movie
called date night starring steve carell
and tina fey way back in the day
uh
i work with taraji p henson that was my
first foray into wow this is a big movie
i remember going into the uh hair and
makeup and there he was
[__] ray liotta with that amazing
head of hair
and i was old billy you know balding
face at that point i was like god jesus
that's what a movie star looks like
and uh he was nice
as can be and funny as hell
and when they said action he just became
like a [__] lunatic
in the best way it was [__] amazing
um
i do remember there was an ex an extra
on that movie
and uh in that scene and the kid came up
to me
and he told me he was from boston
and that he knew mark wahlberg
and i said oh yeah he's on this movie
and the kid went oh yeah is he
i was like you don't know this guy
so he's one of those guys right
so we shoot the scene and the [__]
scene ends
and it was downstairs at a bar i
remember we shot in
downtown l.a and we did the rest of the
movie in new york and um
the scene ended
and
ray got up and he was walking up the
stairs and this [__] extra made a
beeline for him
and was on his hip the whole [__] way
up talking about some script that he
wrote
and uh
i remember just
wanting to tell the kid like just dude
leave him that's not the way you do this
leave him alone
and he was nice about it he's like oh
you know i don't know yeah you know
sounds like a good idea whatever and
like somebody should have gone over and
rescued the guy
but i just remember thinking like that
kid does he's one of those kids who just
didn't [__] get it it's like that's
not how you're gonna get the thing made
um
anyway
so uh
yeah i got to do a couple scene i got to
do a scene with them and we were in new
york on top of that um
silver cup
studios out there in queens we shot the
end when we come in and we arrest all
the bad guys
i believe my line was let me see your
hands that's all i had you know
oh [__] billy freckleface plays a cop
or a fireman that's what i that's what i
play
either that or a ginger in outer space
um
[Laughter]
so anyway yeah he was really really a a
uh
just a nice guy and he was [__]
amazing to watch um
and it was hard to focus on the scene
too because i remember staying across
like that's [__] real ray liotta
i'm doing a scene i got two and a half
lines in a scene
with one of the good fellas [__]
amazing so i'm very thankful that i had
a chance to work with them ever so
briefly and uh obviously
super bummed and devastated that he's
gone
so um
anyways what was i talking about earlier
math
and how the hell i got on that ah sorry
i'm in a [__] bad mood i just
walked up this you know out here to my
uh garage here to do the podcast and uh
i just see this little bird
just on the ground
like lean into one side and i'm looking
at it like why aren't you flying away
and then i looked at it like oh
you're at the end
and like i don't know what to do
and i'm like what does it do now it just
stays there until some reptile realizes
there it is
now
if i was a liberal like a lot of people
think i am which i like to think i am i
always think i'm liberal until i talk to
a liberal then i'm like you're out of
your [__] mind you know
then i go maybe i'm conservative and i
talk to a conservative i'm like this
[__] person it does not make sense
it really is amazing depending on the
jokes that you do how people perceive
you
like i just did that uh netflix thing
which i highly recommend you check out
bill burr presents friends who kill
and i went out there and i'm like all
right what am i gonna do on this thing i
was like i got all this covered [__]
left over i got that written house bit
i'll do those those bits kill
and i know that you know the kovitz
shit's
even though it's still going
it's a good time to get rid of this
and the written house thing nobody
[__] remembers him anymore i'll i'll
do this now right so i do that [__]
and oh my god i didn't even think about
the material i was doing right so i get
these [__]
emails no not emails um
tweets
that was the most unfunny [__] six
minutes of my life
and i'm looking at the avatar of the
person it's like i believe you're old
enough to remember 9 11. i don't i want
to say that that was probably a little
less funny
than whatever the [__] i did on that
netflix thing right and i couldn't
figure out and i got like i don't know i
got like [__] half a dozen of those
like really long
visceral [__] texts
about how that was the worst thing that
ever happened in comedy and i was
thinking like jesus i didn't think i was
that bad
and uh then i figured it out
oh
[Music]
conservative snowflakes they exist yes
they do
uh i thought it was a good bet you know
made fun of [__] i don't know
whatever
it's just a [__] joke right these
[__] idiots oh my god that was
emotional
really well you're on netflix you dumb
[__] what is there 40 000 stand-up
specials go [__] watch another one
acting like you're powerless you were
smart enough to log on to [__]
netflix you're [__] mouth-breathing
dope
just go [__] watch another one
you know there's a bunch of [__] that i
watched during the year where i'm like
this is a steaming pile of [__] i never
think to [__]
you know find out who the person is and
then at them whatever the [__] you do
just thought i'd let you know that i
thought that that sucked
um
anyway so that's what i'm finding i'm
finding out during this new
this new time of doing stand-up that uh
there's just really [__] sensitive
people on both sides
and if you do a topic that they don't
care for
then they're gonna break out you know
i'm someone who has a sense of humor
but that bit about gender neutral
bathrooms had to have been the most
unfunny thing
i have ever seen and i [__]
lost a leg in a blender when i was nine
you know they always have to have like
some [__] horrible thing that
happened to him to just show what a
[__]
bad day is in their life
um
but what are you gonna do i guess it
comes with the territory i don't know
netflix was happy with it and they
signed my check so uh
you know good luck with your long tweet
there missy
these [__] people you know i did you
know by the way i did you know offer the
floor to people that that are into guns
i wanted to hear what you i want to hear
what is your solution to these [__]
school shootings
like how do we solve this not take away
your guns and your second amendment
rights so everybody's happy
um
i don't know what the solution is but i
don't think the solution is
comparing it to the alec baldwin
incident
i'm just like oh all right
there's a [__] leap
what the f i i didn't even that [__]
logic was just like
what
so you're saying a a a [__] negligent
homicide
i don't know who the prop master was on
that set i'm guessing he's related to
leon let whoever the [__] that was
it's a [__] deep cut for sports fans
right there i'm going back like 30 years
um
but uh yeah i don't know how that
compares to a uh
you know pretending to be a cowboy and
not knowing you have a loaded gun
and killing somebody
as opposed to
wanting to shoot up a school with a
semi-automatic weapon and being able to
just walk in as a [__] lunatic
i don't unders and then going and doing
that on purpose i get i don't understand
that comparison and once again i'm
saying i don't want to take away your
guns
i just would like to find a solution
which i think you know
everybody does so i why not ask the gun
owners
that's my question
that is my question for you and i've
asked it twice and i am waiting here
patiently so when you're done cleaning
your [__] rifle there
i would love to hear from you and i'm
not being a [__] either i'm actually i'm
legitimately
asking because there's god there's got
to be a way there's got to be a way
to stop these things
and then let a certain portion
of the uh
american public that wants to own those
guns still be able to go out in their
backyard
and [__] shoot you know
i don't know 860 empty [__] beer cans
whatever the [__] you do with that thing
isn't a semiotic web a semi-automatic
weapon isn't that like if you suck at
shooting
that seems to me like you have a gun
with training wheels on it i feel like
the real badass has just like a sick
shooter
that's all you got that's all i need
um
i just want to have like you know if i
miss the first 38 times to have another
72 chances
um
home protection yeah just in case
someday a platoon attacks me there's
another argument for it is what if
there's a hostile government
which i do find uh
interesting
if there's a hostile government like i
feel like it would work better if
somebody invaded our country
you know what i mean as opposed to a
hostile government because then it's a
home game
and then they're like all right this guy
has weapons and then they'll just have
some nerd fly a drone
into your [__] house and take you out
while you're watching uh you know the
third season of whatever the [__] you're
binge watching
you know i think it's a better argument
that you'd have it you know back in the
day it was the russians
then it became uh
what was it uh all muslim people
some around 9 11 that happened or on 9
11 that happened
and then russia was like uh
russia was like john travolta when he
was making those look who's talking
movies before he did pulp fiction again
and i feel like russia just like pulp
fiction just came out and they're back
russia is back they are a threat again
you know you can't keep a legend down
um
anyway so i don't know what to do with
this bird i just [__] looked out
there it's standing up a little bit more
i don't know maybe it had a couple of
pops at the wrong bird bath who knows
maybe there's some sicko in my
neighborhood you know
somebody gave the wrong vodka for
[__] his birthday and he's like i'm
not drinking this [__] and he just
[__]
spiked the uh
the [__] uh
birdbath
you know what's great about being a bird
though when it comes to flight you know
being semi into aviation like i am
um you never have to worry about an
engine failure
you know what i mean all you have to do
is just feel like you know what i got
enough energy to make it from this tree
or that tree i can do this [__]
nature is so [__] awful man you think
you know if you could fly you're good
just think of all this [__]
as a human being if you could fly all
the [__] danger
that you could avoid
but what does nature do
you know
it creates hawks and birds of prey
so you're on the ground here comes a
[__] cat those bird murdering sons of
[__] right
you fly away and you're like all right
yeah go [__] yourself try jumping up
here there nine lives
what do you say there chicken of the sea
go [__] yourself i'll dive bomb you a
couple times you're laughing
chickadee
you know a little [__] chickadee
flying around
then just some freddy krueger double
freddy krueger gloves
just comes by and [__] grabs you
you're in the midst of doing one of the
greatest things
feelings in the world flight
you're in the midst of that and the
[__] thing comes and just grabs you
flies you back to the nest doesn't kill
you because it's got to teach its new
[__] freddy krueger you know
offspring
how to kill
[__] brutal
it's [__] brutal i don't just you
know you know what i hate was when you
watch one of those
brutal animal videos
where something's getting killed which
for some reason i'm always watching
those things i find it fascinating
the really bad ones there's always some
douche in the comments have to be like i
know this is difficult to watch
but this is nature
oh is that what it is i thought it was
society
you know just just that whole like
they're putting themselves like i know
you can't handle this but i can because
i understand nature you know
did we meet those white guys that sort
of fancy themselves as caucasian
medicine men
like those [__] [__] are always in
the comments and they're always
commenting too
on [__] that's like happening like in
nature in like africa like they've ever
seen anything [__] like that in their
life
um jesus bill
jesus christ one [__] dying bird on
your walk out to the garage and all of a
sudden everybody's getting it
so gun nuts don't think that i'm against
them i actually have gone shooting a
couple of times
all right and uh i enjoyed the hell out
of it i like the [__] revolver
you know i like the band velvet revolver
i like everything about a [__]
revolver
you know i like watching that thing turn
as i shoot rather than looking at the
target
i like how they're usually silver
makes me feel like i have a valuable
piece of uh
i don't know hardware
metal in my
hand know i don't know maybe more
liberals need to go to a gun range
and find the fun side of a gun right and
then they're into guns too and then
maybe we could all just sit down and
stop [__] typing capital letters at
each other i don't know oh bill why
don't you [__] sing we are the world
while you're at it you know what i just
might
there are [__] psychos walking into a
[__] walmart
buying a [__] bazooka
cause it's their right um
you know what you got to do you just got
to get like a [__]
they should just like parole x mobsters
because those guys can read people like
nobody's business and you just stick
them at the behind the counter at the
[__] walmart
and when some crazy [__] comes in
you know
and asks for one of those [__] guns
they just look at him
you want one we want a [__] what
listen i don't think so buddy
take it easy why don't you [__] uh
you the looney tunes why don't you just
[__] uh
they got a whole aisle every flavor
doritos you could ever [__] want one
aisle over this is for this is for the
sane people
you go over there i think they got a
slingshot [__] aisle five why don't
you go [__] with that
you [__] lunatic um
i'm telling you man one of the worst
things we ever did
one of the worst things we ever did was
we [__]
we've shut down the nut houses we shut
down nut houses and then replace those
things with storage centers
allowing people to buy more [__] than
they [__] need
fill the ocean up with plastic in our
streets with crazy people
look at me connecting the dots it all
makes ah when you do a podcast by
yourself and no one can challenge you it
all makes sense
it all makes sense
in my freckled head
i'm solving [__] that i don't understand
but i'm gonna keep on talking
all right um
all right let's let's go positive here
uh
my son absolutely loves my old truck so
does my daughter
and uh
i take him out i take him up and down
the driveway in it you know cause
you can't take kids in that thing right
even if i had like a old-school crew cab
i still wouldn't because
it's like driving a toaster down the
street it's [__] hilarious how people
look at those old trucks and they just
they think that [__] steal
nothing [__]
do a [__] prius t-bones you and that
you're gonna have to get hip replacement
surgery there was no say this is 50
years ago safety well you went through
the [__] windshield with the the
steering wheel impaled into your chest
that's what you're driving
i have all the original suspension on
that thing i take a turn at like seven
miles an hour i have to reach under the
bench seat and hold on to it so i don't
slide into the door
with my lap belt on
[Laughter]
[Music]
so anyway
um my son is always for some reason has
been afraid to get in my truck when it's
in the garage because it's you know it's
kind of dark in there or whatever and i
like i would try to get him to go in and
his little hands would like [__] grab
my t-shirt like i owe them money right
so i don't want him to have a complex so
i got him to you know sort of like you
know pet the seat like nice seat nice
truck nice truck right
so the other day um i think i was
sweeping up the garage or whatever and i
had the truck out and he got up after
his nap
and he just freaked out when he saw it
he was like whoa he's like that ass
truck damn
truck it ain't just speaking gibberish
pointing at it
and i'm [__] cracking up and i go you
want to go down and sit in it and he's
like he's like yeah that's his big word
yeah
give him something he's like thank you
you're like yo i'm like you're welcome
he just goes yeah
[Music]
i think he's got the weight of the world
on his shoulders it's the funniest [__]
ever
um i'm gonna try that out to my wife
tonight i'm gonna see you tonight it's
gonna be like
hey sweetheart i love you she's gonna be
like oh i love you too i'm just gonna go
yeah
i mean i don't know what
i don't know having kids is the greatest
it is the greatest [__] thing that
could ever happen to you man it's
amazing so anyway they both love my
truck so
i put my son finally gets in the truck
and i started it up
and he's making you know he's imitating
the engine he's going um
[Music]
he loved it right
so i've done it a couple times and
yesterday we were just sitting you know
because i haven't driven it
uh this week you know busy with the
editing the movie so
i need to start it up so the battery
doesn't go dead on me so i was
had it on idle and he was sitting there
with me and he was just watching my foot
when i was just sort of revving the
engine a little bit
and then he just looked up at me and he
just smiled and i was just like oh my
god
my son's gonna be a car guy
my son loves truck so you [__]
kidding me and my daughter loves it too
i'm already teaching her how to shift
the thing
um
which i'm absolutely gonna do they're
absolutely gonna learn how to drive that
thing without a doubt but uh i kind of
got the green light
with the f250 my dream truck i always
wanted to have a brand new f-250 regular
cab four-wheel drive with the big
[__] diesel engine that i could
[__] tow a goddamn house down the
street even though i don't know how to
fix anything i just [__] like it
okay
it's funny you know i when i bought my
old truck i remember this guy giving me
[__] yeah you got a truck i'm like yeah
he's like you're going to put [__] in
the back of it
it's like i like trucks
somebody buys a muscle car do you go
you're going to go down [__] race you
know
go down go down to the airport when it
shuts down and race somebody for [__]
pink slips no you're allowed to have it
why can't you [__] have a truck
enough with the truck shaming people
so um
what was i gonna say uh
they're both totally into the thing and
uh
you know these little electric car cars
that they make now that these kids can
drive like my daughter i'm like i put
two hockey sticks down
in the garage we play like parking at
target
and she like backs in she's like got her
arm like
around like the little plastic headrest
right of the passenger seat she's
looking over her shoulder and i'm just
[__] cracking up
like she's gonna know how to parallel
park
uh by the time she's six
so um
now that my uh my son is totally into
trucks i saw that they make an electric
electric car it's a little ford f-150
and i'm like i got to get him that
i got to get him that i mean
how do you not i already for his
birthday i got on the celtics
uh track suit
with a little pair of baby jordan threes
that had a little green streak in him
dude he just he looked like he was
[__]
a rookie
on the baby celtics
i'm not lying my son's got a vibe toy is
a vibe he just you know you take a
picture of him he just kind of looks
over
you know like he just had a hit movie
telling me he's got a he's the kid has
got a vibe and my wife is just
completely enamored with them it's the
greatest thing ever
um
so anyway hey how about the celtics uh
warriors how about that series all tied
up at two
games a piece let's how about a round of
applause for the officiating crew doing
their job in the nba
now they can let them play
now we're going to see who's the better
team the nba officials have done what
they're supposed to do they have made
sure that this [__] game
is gonna go at least six games hopefully
seven now i know they didn't have to
intervene in the last game because steph
curry went off but if he didn't go off
then they would have gone they would
have done what they had to [__] do
and i'm not [__] saying that they're
out to get the celtics i'm saying they
would have done that to the warriors if
they were up two games to one it's just
it's how it is
it's got to go long
people have to get to know these players
this is the new cast the new jennifer
anistons courtney cox all of that
you know
we need a wacky next door neighbor every
every team seems to have to have one guy
who's a little crazy
who says you know says the things you're
not supposed to say i'm telling you it's
[__] cast
like a goddamn movie so i haven't really
watched since game
i get watched game one and two and i was
just like all right i can't
yeah game two i i just was
like i don't wanna be behaving like an
[__] in front of my kids so
i'm recording the whole thing
i'm going to watch it win or lose
because it's part of sports history so
i'm going to watch it
because i don't know if you guys noticed
i'm not a big reader
all right i'm not into the soliloquies
there
um
but like i'm not gonna watch it while
like my kids are around and uh i just
like
i just you know what it is i i can't
handle the nba game i just can't handle
the game where you're up by [__] 20
points and then like three minutes later
you're down by five
it's just like i'm i'm too
i i don't have the uh emotional
i don't know the way i'm wired
i i've had too many volatile moments in
my life i don't need to watch a sport
that's going to give me a [__] heart
attack
every five minutes i i just don't
okay and then you combine the fact that
you
know you know i'm not going to go off in
the officiating anymore i'm done i'm
done with that [__] um
so anyway i had a great [__] weekend
it's my birthday weekend oh billy boy's
54.
54 and looking good
looking good you know i mean i'm closer
to the grave there but i'm i'm looking
good
okay
it's gonna be a nice light box
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh
i'm not doing that i'm [__] cremating
without a doubt people like well you
know aren't you nervous we're gonna
[__] burn you up it's like i'd rather
well what am i gonna die again and if i
die again get it over with i'll lay
there for [__]
how long does it take
even if it's [__] 20 minutes
to turn into ashes as opposed to if
you're still alive laying in the ground
in the dark waiting for the worms to
come [__] that
all day plus you know what i mean
it's one of the stupidest things ever to
have a [__] grave
here lies this [__] guy who's no
longer here you know so stupid
so dumb you know
especially with the environment they
should be using dead people as
fertilizer if we didn't eat so much [__]
you know what i mean can you imagine
that all the mcdonald's you ate going
into the soil that would be the [__]
end of us
um i gotta be honest with you well all
the [__] quarter pounds of cheese
i've eaten in my lifetime uh when they
cremate me dude it's gonna be a quick
one
it's gonna go up like a [__] bowling
alley
now there's an old school expression uh
went up like a [__] bowling alley
i don't know why they used to say that i
think i always wondered why
i only heard like
a few people use that expression when i
was a kid
i remember asking somebody said oh it's
the wax they put on the lanes it's like
that sounds like you just made that up
made sense to me as a kid
uh i just remember i tried to use that
expression when i was younger i was like
yeah i'll go up like a [__] bowling
alley and all my friends were looking at
me like what are you 102 years old where
the [__] the deck and i was like all
right
i won't say that anymore sorry
sorry
um
i did a couple of sets this weekend
first one didn't go so well second one
went great i got a bunch of new [__]
already replacing the [__] that the
[__] conservative snowflakes the six
of them didn't [__] like
i'm ready to go i'm ready to go
ready to go and i got uh what do i got
reading wilkes-barre pennsylvania
this weekend a couple uh coming up a
couple other whatever i'm gonna run my
hour make sure i'm ready to go for that
[__] and then i also had a chance to
play some drums
i also took my kid to a birthday party
drove him in the old truck
went swimming
oh billy big weekend
um
anyway let me let me do the reads here
before i talk your [__] ears off
about this uh the red sox huh
great road trip
32 and 29 we are we're up
with three games
over 500 and what i love
is it doesn't matter how good the
yankees are doing because there's the
wild card now
it's insane
it's almost like they reward people for
not doing well
uh what is it all about money
uh butcher box everybody
butcher box this summer add some power
players to your grilling lineup with
butcher box butcher box is the
subscription service that delivers high
quality meat man and seafood right to
your doorstep choose from a carefully
curated selection of 100 grass-fed beef
free-range organic chicken wild caught
seafood you don't know what they're
gonna do
and more
i mean let's be honest people do you
remember when the [__] covert first
came out if you believed in it
right
everybody went down there bought up all
the food and all the [__] toilet
paper
just imagine if you have your
you know you got the freezer now
you know
in your garage that extra freezer you
pack it up with some butcher blocks
everybody's freaking out
you know
you're wiping your ass with whatever
they wrap the flounder in
and you're eating like a [__] king
all you need is solar panels on top of
your house
and a gun turret you got at walmart
you're [__] good to go
um
i'll tell you right now do you know
that's what i love about people that
know how to modify [__] there's somebody
out there in a [__]
military graveyard is taking a gun
turret off of a [__]
one of those b-29 bombers whatever the
[__] they were
inverting it oh no the one on top you do
take the one on top and just put it on
on top of your house
that's it right there that's what you do
you get bulletproof glass you get one of
those
you know it probably has the [__]
hand cranks
spin yourself around
no one's getting your [__] uh and right
now new subscribers can receive a free
grilling bundle in their first order
come on man the summer time it's all
about grilling convenience every month
butcher bucks ships a curated selection
of high quality meat right to your home
free shipping for the continental united
states no antibiotics or added hormones
all right
so you can feed this to your kids and
your daughter won't get her period when
she's seven years old that's a good
thing packed fresh and shipped frozen
for convenience so you can save time on
your next grocery store trip customize
your own box or go with one of theirs
either way you get exactly what you want
high quality meat delicious 100
grass-fed beef free-range organic
chicken pork raised crate free
i like my pigs running around
uh and wild caught seafood the ted
nugent of food unbeatable value less
than six dollars per meal on average get
summer
sizzling started with this special
butcher box deal for our listeners free
bacon for life for the life of your men
for life of your membership free bacon
plus ten dollars off ah burning that up
on a sunday morning
you got potatoes left over from saturday
night
yeah you're out there grilling you got
restless leg syndrome it's smelling so
good sign up today at butcherbox.com
to get one pack of free bacon in every
box for the life of your membership plus
10 off your first order and you got free
bacon
free [__] bacon for the next time
they shut down the [__] grocery
stores that's butcherbox.com and use the
code bird to claim this deal
start stocking up on your free bacon
um
i'll tell you right now you know where
you're gonna get that guy out of that
[__] house
he's got a lifetime worth of free bacon
and [__] a gun turret from a big 29
bomber on top of his house you want to
go get him cause i don't
i'd rather stay out here in this [__]
perimeter and let him slowly eat himself
to an early grave that's our only option
um
if he's got a lifetime supply a [__]
bacon how much cereal you think you got
in that house
jesus christ mike use your [__] head
stamps.com everybody oh i love
stamps.com you know when you're running
a small business every second counts
well not if you're doing it right maybe
you're your own boss you could chill a
little bit you can't afford to waste a
single moment so why are you still
taking time out of your day to go to the
post office when you could be using
stamps.com instead stamps.com making
mailing and shipping quick easy and cost
effective stamps.com saves you time
money and stress for more than 20 years
stamps.com has been indispensable for
over one million businesses streamline
your shipping process with stamps.com
easy to use software
uh all you need is your regular computer
and printer no special supplies or
equipment uh you're up and running in
minutes printing official postage for
any letter any package anywhere you want
to send it stop wasting time and start
saving money when you use stamps.com to
mail and ship
sign up with promo code burr for a
special offer that includes a four-week
trial plus free shipping and a digital
scale no long-term commitments or
contracts
what do you think we're doing over here
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
and enter code burr
b-u-r-r
you know i mentioned a while back i
mentioned it i floated it out there to
see if you guys would take the no i
didn't mention it i was talking how i
became a coffee drinker
at 53 now 54 years old foa
50 tree
50 foa
one two three tree was new york
tidy toy street i remember that guy on
the downtown six next stop tidy tide
street
i felt like i was in a sylvester and
tweety cartoon
um
so
i started with a cappuccino
i don't like regular coffee and then i
eventually just moved to espresso with
nothing in it no calories no nothing
just give me the [__] gas and you
know what i realized
the reason why coffee is so popular in
this country
because we don't have siestas
they don't let you take a nap in the
afternoon that's what the [__] you need
that's what you're plowing through if
you get eight hours sleep you don't need
coffee in the morning
all right but then what happens you know
you get older in the afternoon your
body's like hey why don't we just take
you know
a little 10-15 minutes that's all i need
the other day i was in the editor
editing room and i was laying on the
couch
and i and and my writing partner i go
you just edit the next few minutes just
hang on a second and i just put my
sweatshirt over my head i fell asleep
for eight minutes i [__] woke up i
felt like i had a double shot of
espresso i was ready to go
i was chopping
i was slicing i was dicing
um
so that's what i'm kind of realizing
because i just took a [__] nap before
i did this podcast
you know i was laying on the couch oh my
god god i gotta go out there and run my
[__] freckled yap for a goddamn hour
and i was feeling tired i'm like can i
just close my eyes here for a second
you know what i mean
fell asleep with my somehow my arm's
over my head because i put the pillow
over my my eyes my eyes
and i woke up eight minutes later
refreshed and i couldn't feel from like
my shoulders down because my [__]
arms fell asleep
[Laughter]
but i feel good
um all right
somebody sent me this fifth fatality at
the isle of man tt race
um i actually when this came in i
usually just read them
like
as i'm talking to you guys but that i
had to look up now the isle of man race
is on the isle of man
um
which is i believe
i was going to go to this thing i had i
had
everything lined up i was trying to line
up a gig i was going with my buddy of
mine i was going to go to this [__]
thing before all this covic [__]
happened
and um
it's the most
insane motorcycle race out there uh
they've had more deaths than years that
they've had it
and these people just
drive a million miles an hour through
these little farm towns i don't know how
they do it but they've had five
fatalities this year alone
says hey bill really don't mean to spam
you maybe you follow this news yourself
but two more fatalities today
i'm just morbidly curious about the tt
race i'm not that into motor racing but
i've threatened to go to it for years
with my brother who's a big petrol head
uh you might be interested in the story
of the dunlop family from northern
ireland maybe you know them
um no of them i think is what you're
trying to say uh dunlop like the tires
and all of that stuff
big name in racing uh the gist is the
most successful isle of man tt writer
ever was joey dunlop
oh okay with 26 victories over the years
jesus christ he was killed in a bike
road race in estonia
in 2000
um his brother robert dunlop had five tt
victories all right
okay i'm i'm gonna go out on a limb here
and say the dunlop family from ireland
is some of the
toughest people
god ever created here his brother robert
dunlop had two five tt victories so but
in that family they had a total of 31
victories
he was killed in a road race in northern
ireland in 2008
the northwest 200. robert had two sons
william and michael and they featured in
the documentary road
oh they are featured in the aqua
documentary road well i'm watching that
which is worth checking out
uh william was killed in a bike road
race just outside dublin in 2018. my god
jesus christ
this is like a reverse pixar movie
uh his brother michael who has lost his
uncle
father and brother still races bikes and
won two events in the isle of man tt
this year he is now third on the list of
most wins
the mentality of some of these writers
is fascinating all the best i mean it's
got to be the most interesting interview
ever all right island man
roger bradley roger and bradley stockton
die in a sidecar crash
so this was a father and son
i've been killed in a car
in a crash during the racing of the isle
of man tt organizers have confirmed the
pair from crew
i hope i said that right c-r-e-w-e both
died as a result of the incident at
aggo's leap
oh boy
during the second lap of the second
sidecar race on friday passenger bradley
21 was a newcomer to the event while his
father roger 56
last competed at the tt in 2017.
five riders have now died at the event
this year holy [__]
um
i gotta be honest like the isle of man
is the closest thing to what
racing was
you know back in the day in like the 50s
and 60s where people did like you got in
the car and you were seriously risk just
a car
you were seriously risking death i i've
recommended this book
a number of times there's a book out
there called the limit
and it's about the uh
the first f1
champion that was american-born
and um
aside from an amazing accomplishment is
just the amount
of death
that there was back then and uh i know
i've talked about this before in the
podcast but forget about on the track
into the crowd like the the safety in
the cars
wasn't there
and it certainly wasn't there for the
crowd and these [__] guys would hit
each other and their cars would just go
flying into the crowd
and they'd killed like [__] i don't
know five fifteen [__] people it was
insane
um
and it's really amazing like the uh
level of safety that they've uh
been able to achieve over the years
because of you know they always learn
through people [__] dying same thing
with aviation
so it becomes super safe because people
give up their lives there um
is there a place to there's got to be a
place to watch that live
um that race every year uh it's it is
[__] that is no joke that's you're
putting on your big boy pants there so
rest in peace to all five of those
riders all everybody over there
um i don't know how they get the their
balls into the [__] riding lettuce
um
those are some
throwback throwback people um much
respect all right nerds out of control
uh there's gonna be some gun nut well
how come you're not saying bad
motorcycles
uh nerds out of control uh dear billy
bong
did you see this article going around
about the google engineer who quit
because he had a conversation with an ai
computer and he came to realize that it
was fully aware of of what it was saying
and what it was doing
the computer starts explaining that even
though it's a computer there's no
difference between it and a human
if that's not the writing on the wall i
don't know what is
uh if you own google would you have the
whole thing shut down yes
or placate to the robots and try inside
with them assuming that if you tried and
kill them they might strike back first i
figure at some point they've they've so
[__] up
with these robots because you know what
they're gonna do with these robots these
robots are gonna be the michael jordan
of everything
you know you have a buddy he's really
good at reading people you know but he
sucks at math
you know
michael jordan of basketball you know
what i'm saying people everybody gets a
gift
that's not true but you know they like
to tell people that but you know the
greats all get gifts right
they're gonna basically make something
that can dunk from the half court line
that is a marx knows it's gonna be like
rambo the [__] thing is gonna be like
rambo and then they're gonna give it a
[__] porn star robot dick it's going
to be able to [__] any woman better than
any guy it's the dumbest [__]
i just don't understand
why they're doing this uh anyway
assuming you had uh
let's see where was it assuming that if
you try and kill them they might strike
back first like you tell your wife over
breakfast i think we have a problem with
these robots then before you can do
anything about it the toaster blows up
in your face yeah i would say um
there has to be a safe word
that shuts them down i the problem is
with this
is you're dealing with nerds
okay
and if you go back to the great 80s film
weird science
what was it it was a couple of nerds
they wanted to get laid
and rather than [__] just learning
how to talk to women
they used their smarts and they just
built a woman
you know and it was all done like it was
this funny thing they had bras on their
head and [__] but i think there was a
real deeper message there
so i mean i saw an article uh
that said the first sex robots are
coming out i mean it's it's this is
gonna be
i don't think global warming is gonna
take us out
[Laughter]
um so my only thing is what i think
might be going on here
is
uh
this is their way
that they're going to solve
both rebellion
and the world population
is they're going to create
a world of robots
to replace all of us
so they'll never have to worry about
being taken out of power and then they
can just bang tens
all the [__] time
and it'll just be like you know like
they had like the five families
in the new york mafia they'd be like
they'll be like a family that survives
and like maybe each continent or
something like that i don't know what
no you can't have that then you're back
to adam and eve and then you got your
[__]
relatives banging each other they'll be
they'll be you know you got to have
enough of a mix there so
you know
we're not complete morons um
by the way that was my arm rubbing on
the chair for people are always going
did you pass every time i shift in this
[__] chair
um
see listen
i can't do it and i won't be able to do
it
uh whatever
um
what is it if you own google would you
yeah it's i i don't uh
all right let me do i really want to
click on this
i try to stay away from this type of
[__] because i used to click on stuff
like this all the time and it was just
so [__] unsettling like watching
these people filming uh lake mead drying
up
and nobody's talking about that you know
what i mean
you know like me drying up in the the
drought in the southwestern part of this
country
uh
evidently my set on friends who kill
was sadder than what's going on out here
evidently according to some of these
[__] idiots all right righteous
vegans hey billy beets oh i love a beet
salad
oh don't get me started i love a beet
okay i don't want to beat on my burger
australia but i love a beet salad uh my
sister-in-law is a righteous vegan
every way of life
you know maybe if there was a yellow
beet i bet it tastes good maybe i had
the wrong beet on the burger i just
thought it overpowered the patty it was
as thick as the patty made no sense
then again the burger's not their thing
right
you don't see us over here trying to
make a vegemite sandwich uh every way of
life okay my sister is a righteous vegan
oh god
can you send her a shut the [__] up from
me
just eat your [__] plants and shut up
every way of life that isn't modeled
like hers is immoral ah that's fun to be
around everyone who eats meat or
consumes butter is either an [__] or
ignorant
oh jesus
okay well that's two strikes against me
uh we get along but i have no problem
throwing counter points at her god bless
you
like what the [__] do you think happens
to all the animals who live on the land
you're farming
killing one deer and eating for six
months is less of an impact on the
ecosystem than tilling up a few football
fields to yield one salad
not to mention the almonds and all the
water they need bill yeah that's true
there's nothing wrong with any of that
[__] there's just two there's just too
many [__] people we have to figure
out how we're gonna do this
i'm glad i don't have to figure it out
um i've never hunted
nor shot an arrow and i don't see myself
doing it anytime soon so this isn't some
uh camo draped by us uh bias
i work in insurance
i love hunters man i think if anybody
who can [__] go out
track something kill it
skin it clean it take the meat go home
start a fire in the [__] wilderness i
mean those are like
incredibly incredible skills that if
you're not an [__] you should be 100
envious of it maybe learn how to do it
um i want to do the city version where i
learn how to [__] eat my neighbor
when i'm sick of squirrel stew
um all right
so i sent this article about how vegan
leather is primarily made of fossil
fuels and she accused me of conflating
issues
um
could fl what is conflating me
is that what i was accusing some gun
people of earlier hang on a second
let me see what is conflating me oh
jesus christ
yeah you can laugh at me most my
listeners are like i don't know what a
[__] it means either
i know what inflating means conflate
gerund or present participle conflating
i thought that was the [__]
definition
gerund i was like what the [__] does
that mean combined
two or more text ideas etc into one the
urban crisis conflates a number of
different economic and social issues
oh so there's a way of doing it when you
see 360 and then there's a way that
you're just saying that you're you're
sticking [__] together that doesn't go
together okay
um anyways uh she said you're conflating
issues and this guy says thought all
areas of the planet intersected but
apparently not according to my
sister-in-law the genius
oh man you just gotta let this [__] go
i'll tell you bill the blinders you have
to live with in order to live a happy
principled life i'm telling you you you
got it figured out you just got to go oh
yeah you know what i like to do with
people like that
i just like to listen
and you just let him talk and talk and
talk and talk and talk and then
eventually
if there is a god
they run out of [__] to say
and you haven't argued with them
you're just listening
and when they're done
you just go
oh okay
hey where are we watching uh game five
tonight you just change the subject
it [__] infuriates him
you didn't listen
i said it for 20 minutes and didn't say
a word
i presented
no opposite that you just argue you just
want to you just want to argue i don't
want to argue
i respect your opinion
i don't want to argue
okay put your eyebrows down okay it's
over
uh anyways this guy says uh
you know here's the article so you know
i'm not bullshitting you uh thanks and
go [__] yourself you bald angel well i'd
click on the article but i everybody's
full of [__] for all i know this is
coming from the people that make cow
leather i don't know is it true and i'm
not gonna [__] sit here and try to
debunk or or or or what is it what they
call vet a [__] article on um
plant-based leather jackets
nice leather jacket it smells like
broccoli at least it doesn't sell it
smells like a dead animal
oh dead animals smell better than that
[__] thing
uh things i should have said
ah dear billy beanbag uh
i hope that reference will count as an
insult
they all count as insults that's why i
left jesus christ what do you think i'm
dumb i don't know did you spell bean
right b-e-a-n-e is that i spelled bean
bag i thought it was like the bean
b-e-a-n um as as i am from the oakland
bay area
and he has traded uh away every star for
two minor leaguers and a player to be
named later
oh i'm sorry
i didn't get the joke billy bean the
[__] owner of uh
the oakland a's
dear billy beanbag i hope that will
count as an insult meaning billy bean is
an insult where he's from because he's
from the oakland bay area and the owner
of his team has traded away every
started two mi for two minor leaguers
and a player to be named later yeah
absolutely and that's why they're gonna
[__] move to vegas it's a [__]
shame
um i was having a night in with my lady
she suggested we watch battlestar
galactica which i had never seen great
show by the way the tv series
that thing
the cylon raiders
um
is that what you're talking about they
make a movie of it i don't know things
get spicy
oh you're watching battlestar galactica
she goes he goes things get spicy i'm
tagging her from behind
she seems to be enjoying it good for me
she turns her head around to make eye
contact
but she sees that i'm actually still
watching the episode oh no
she flips the [__] out i went straight
to deer in the headlights and i forgot
what words i mustered at yam and
yammered afraid to hurt her feelings
looking back
i wanted to say
you're the one that told me to watch it
it's a good show it's a good show just
look forward
and then just finished thanks and have a
nice day also kudos to this celtics for
picking up game one oh that's from a
little while back
um
yeah you could have been like do you
realize the level of concentration it
takes to keep a [__] erection while
watching battlestar galactica
i mean this is a fascinating series this
is like when you watch those things on
discovery about how the planet came to
be the way it is
i've watched those my whole life i don't
ever remember having a hat on
um
that's [__] hilarious first of all
god bless your woman huh doggy style
turn around for a little eye contact you
know i mean she's i mean she she's a
gamer i don't know what the [__] your
problem is
sitting there watching you know who says
nerds don't get laid good for you man
you're watching sci-fi and [__]
hooking up i like this guy i like i like
this whole relationship and you're a
baseball fan god bless you well actually
no she's the sci-fi nerd
um
well i don't know i don't even know what
i didn't i think you're conflating two
issues here sci-fi and doggy style sex
i have a new word and i will use it
while i still remember it for the next
[__] six hours all right that's the
podcast everybody god bless you i'm not
[__] with you gun owners i'm
seriously asking because i know none of
us wants that to happen to our children
so i'm trying to have this maybe be a
place where i don't know
people can talk to each other without
yelling
um which is [__] hilarious coming
from me considering i've spent most my
life yelling at people
um what do you think about that you
toxic white male shut up all right
that's it go [__] yourselves have a
great couple of days and i'll check in
on ya on thursday
how do i shut this off